what would you do if you could not chew
the dr. Seuss write this script or maybe
roald dahl what would you do if you
could not true simple you just brash
your food apart
alligators go through two to three
thousand teeth in a lifetime seems
inefficient but hey they haven't evolved
in millions of years so if it ain't
broke why fix it females also keep an
obsessive vigil over a mound of
decomposing brush and mud why within lye
three dozen eggs but she needs to be in
fresh water to survive she's dug a small
wallow near her nest to rest in the
water while keeping an eye on it
helicopter parent typical he or she can
relax and let her heartbeat drop to two
beats per minute I wish I could get that
kind of rest when her eggs begin to
hatch she digs them up and inspects them
one by one her monstrous jaws spell doom
for her prey but a comfy nursery for her
babies as she ferries them to the river
they're like the minivans of the
reptilian world she'll look after them
for up to a year or more fiercely
defending them from all threats
including raccoons and other Gators if I
was a raccoon I would not mess with a
baby alligator
just seeing that footage of it killing
that deer are you kidding he'll eat a
frog or something come on your life is
short
[Music]
you